foreign
let's roll off and talk to Grant in
Spokane Washington what's up Grant
I am doing uh I'm doing well thanks for
having me on your show I'm looking
forward to getting some feedback all
right let's figure it out man what's up
all right I've been diagnosed with a
bipolar diagnosis about four and a half
years ago okay initially it was bipolar
type two and then more recently it's
been bipolar type one my question is how
do I live an emotionally healthy life
for my wife and our five children
hmm
uh what what
did you have a significant manic episode
that had them re-diagnose you
um they just uh they they thought that I
had more of a depressive episodes okay
that were more affecting my life but
according to the diagnosis you need to
have a manic episode for more than five
consecutive days and typically my my
diagna or my my high phases last seven
to ten days
okay
um what what
um
what have you done to manage care over
the last four and a half years
have you kept yourself well medication
that wasn't working effectively okay I
think I think I was just I was too loyal
to her to a health system that that
wasn't specialized in mental health just
kind of a general practitioner here in
Spokane yeah and um yeah I've made a
change recently to something that
specializes in mental health and I see a
counselor on a weekly basis and I see my
my psychiatrist probably I've been with
them about 90 days and I've seen her
probably half a dozen times in those 90
days Wow have you seen a uptick in your
mood and stabilization
feeling better yes yeah I think so good
deal man that's excellent hey can I just
tell you this just got a guy uh husband
to husband I'm proud of you
thanks good for you and there's days
that um you feel good and you don't want
to take your meds because you feel like
I'm good man and you take them anyway
and I'm proud of you
it's hard okay
yep I'm proud of you all right so how do
you be a good partner to wife five kids
what's precipitated this
did something happen did you do
something what like why why today
my wife and I we've been separated about
11 months
um my my oldest daughter she's gonna
turn 13 in about two weeks okay and she
and I are not on a talking terms
I've uh I've traumatized her and I've
said terrible things through and acted
in atrocious ways when I've been
unstable and she just doesn't want me to
be in her life at all okay and uh our
marriage is
man our marriage is hanging on barely
um
sounds like it's over brother
like y'all have been separated for
almost a year now it sounds like it's
over is this you not
holding is this not you not
acknowledging reality or is your is your
wife saying no we're still working
through this
I don't know
when I called when I called the Dave
Ramsey Show I talked to Ken Coleman and
George Campbell and he said a number one
protect the kids and a number one a this
fight to save the marriage and fighting
to save the marriage looks like taking
care of my mental health making my
appointments taking my meds and then
number two fighting to save the marriage
is call before I come over and create
positive memories and work on chores
with the kids and saying stuff like I
notice these chores which one is more
higher priority my spouse hold on so I
want to I want to reframe that a little
bit okay
taking your meds
getting counseling
moving your body and exercising and
putting good food into your body like
getting some sleep
that isn't to save your marriage that's
for you to be well and whole
and when you get well in whole
and you get stabilized
and you have some coping mechanisms for
when your body starts to drag you
underwater which you've experienced and
when your body duct tapes you to a
rocket ship which you've experienced
when you get some coping strategies and
some behavior management strategies on
on those during those seasons
then you are in a place
to begin to work on your marriage
and it sounds like semantics but it's a
huge difference here's why if your
marriage is over
if your wife has all but left you which
it sounds like she has
you still need to take your meds and
work on having a good life you got five
kids that need their dad okay you
deserve a life of peace and you haven't
had that in a long long time
right
that would be correct okay
so our Focus right now is getting Grant
well and healthy
and that will allow you to focus on the
kids that will allow you to
focus on your marriage
and
um let me try to say this in a right way
that's kind
um
when's the
this is a I don't want to paint everyone
with bipolar in this in this in with one
broad stroke okay but
um here is something I've seen with the
limited number of folks I've worked with
they are very very very smart
lightning smart and on up Seasons they
are able to their computational power is
so much faster and so much more vast
than than a normal guy like me
and they're able to see solutions to
problems sometimes it don't even exist
yet
but they create solutions to situations
and that's often good unless those
problems are relational
and then what you end up doing is coming
up with the ways you're going to save
your marriage and you forget to ask your
wife
and then you start doubling down on a
bunch of activities and actions and they
don't work because it's not part of what
your wife needs to be whole in this
marriage and then it's agonizing and
frustrating and then your body starts
flipping switches on you
am I on the right path
I'm I'm trying to keep up with you okay
so when's the last time you sat down
with your wife and said what's the
status of our marriage
um I think at the beginning of October
we we pushed pause on marriage
counseling for three months and
we'd been seeing a marriage counselor on
a weekly basis for 90 days or so okay
why who who pushed pause and why
I think financially we
financially we've come to the end of the
financial resources okay
um
and just not seeing any progress or
change or difference I I can't point to
one thing and say this is different from
the last 90 days okay
has she filed for divorce yet she filed
for illegal separation yet we've talked
about illegal separation okay
let's go to your kids you're a 13 year
old right now is right
okay
she's right
you scared the hell out of her
you said some tough stuff
and for a 13 year old now you're what
you're doing my brothers you're playing
a long game
okay the dad's well dad's gonna take his
medication dad's going to not grovel and
try to earn your love back
but your dad's just going to keep
showing up and keep showing up because I
love you and if she says I don't want
you in my presence you're gonna say cool
I love you here's what we want we're
going to play a game that's a long game
that's 10 years from now
so at 23 here's what I want her to have
a handwritten letter from her dad every
two weeks for 10 years
okay telling her how she's doing how
proud of her you are
make the letter about her make her the
hero of the letter not about that this
is about her how much you love her
how proud of what a beautiful young
woman she is what a gritty brilliant
young woman she is
um
I want her to have a firm understanding
about how loved she is
and at the same time I want to respect
her autonomy that she gets to choose to
not be terrified and scared again for a
while
it's both and okay
is that fair
I think that's her okay what about your
other kids
um our 11 year old
doesn't live at home anymore
um she she and my wife don't have the
best relationship and then we have an
eight-year-old a six-year-old and a
three-year-old boy so we had four
daughters of another son okay
but the younger three they still want me
in their Library so
appreciate me coming back so like it me
being involved in their life
um
my my 11 year old
isn't as hospital as prickly as my 13
year old okay but I I think doing the
letter thing if I can do it for one of
them I could probably do it for each one
of them and that probably would be
healthy
for them to look back on the past yep I
know I would have appreciated it from my
dad yeah and here's a cool thing about
um
foreign go have a visit with your three
kids that want to hang out with you you
go through a visit with those three and
you'll have a great time
they remember the feelings
but they don't always remember exactly
what Dad said
and if you say something dumb over the
next few years which if you're a parent
you for sure will I know I will
um our bodies have a way of remembering
the negative stuff more than the
positive stuff and
ex-spouses have a
more likely to bring up well your dad
said that right negative stuff
the beauty of having a letter is they
can read it over and over and over again
it crystallizes in their mind how
valuable and beautiful and wonderful and
gritty and smart they are so says
they're dead you see what I'm saying
hey yes sir
um
your daughter is living with your aunt
why isn't she why aren't any of these
kids living with you have you had your
kids removed
have they been taken from you
I know that we've had uh CPS cases over
the last probably
uh five years and they were because of
action that I had
neglect that probably would be able to
be using the figure blinded it means
what'd you do
I need you to talk directly into the
phone too it's starting to fade a little
bit uh what happened I
I let a two-year-old go out and you know
winter scene with snow on the ground and
all she had was a diaper on I did
realize that she'd gone out of the house
the neighbor found her brought her back
okay what else
um my kid's reporting to the nurse at
school if they didn't feel safe at home
okay
were you violent with them
probably
I don't remember it I don't remember
specific
instances of being violent towards them
I did there was a time when I took a
door off of the changes and showed
violence that way towards our house and
I I was out of control okay
so here's what it sounds like the
greatest gift you can give your kids
right now is for you to be well
okay and this is hard to hear but you're
doing the right things right now
you're gonna have to keep working real
real hard and there's going to be a
there's going to be it's just going to
take time
uh smashing a door off its hinges in
your house with four little kids or five
little kids is trauma that's what that
is and you know that I'm not gonna kick
you while you're down
um you can't put that door back on the
hinges and you can't sweep up all the
pieces of the door that are on the floor
and rebuild it and say hey it's all good
what you have to do over a long period
of time is get yourself stable and get
yourself well and you're doing the right
things you got a full-time psychiatrist
you got a full-time therapist you're
doing the work
do the work for Grant
because Grant deserves to be whole
and then do it for those kids
it sounds to me my brother like your
marriage is over and I think it's time
for some very concrete conversations
with your wife are you done
is this entity over you will always be
in relationship with her because you'll
share five kids
always is this done because you're
spending a lot of energy trying to keep
together a Unity that might be over
okay let's get some very clear answers
here
and let's not ever stop taking our meds
let's not ever hop out of counseling
okay and let's work a long game to get
ourselves well in whole so that we are
safe around our kids not so we show them
and trick them so that we become safe in
their presence
and kids have a pretty uncanny knack for
feeling it
glassy-eyed dad versus oh Dad sees me
there he is
that's one two three four years down the
road let's work towards that my brother
okay
thanks for being brave thanks for trying
to turn the sucker around you're worth
it they're worth it keep fighting my man